oh wait a minute
this is supposed to be a yud
but it's a hay
what
you know mark on it
a jeweler's mistake
[Music]
what does that look like to you
hi
that is not a mistake it's a cipher
my
3.1415926
you memorized by
part of it
did a competition in college once got to
the
417th character only 417.
i got hungry
okay so starting
from there first number's three circle
the third character
then one circle the fourth okay four
circle the eighth and so on
[Music]
okay so we have 14 letters that spell
let's see
[Music]
nothing
but it's a jumble there must be another
step one veil lifts to reveal another
do you recognize the number
no
hello
oh good my text worked i will send
unknown calls to voicemail so who was
this
in a way sato with central intelligence
i'm a friend i was hoping to talk to
robert uh
robert
we don't have time mr bellamy peter's in
trouble i don't want anyone else getting
hurt
hello langdon
what do you think you're doing
i'm trying to help peter you're going to
get yourself hurt
or catherine
i'm giving you a chance to come out on
your own or
robert
let's go
you just hung up on the c.i.a they're uh
outside
let's go
wait wait wait wait wait
damn somebody's coming through the
tunnels
is there any other way out
what about this
that's the old conveyor system i know
you said it goes to the other buildings
right the system hasn't been in use for
years but does it still work
it's worth a shot
[Music]
you want us to go in there
robert it'll be okay
i'll go first
in case of emergency
[Music]
i'm sorry
but the library's closed where are they
much further
it's not far i can see the light i can't
see anything my eyes are closed
just try to relax and enjoy the ride
oh no
it's okay
oh no
it's
be
okay
[Music]
[Music]
you're okay
you're okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you